abone ol
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
ve
selamlarımı olsun Herkese yapan
ayarlardan Yasemin ben ben normalde
kendimi tanıtırken adından soygundan
sonra ilk söylediğim şeyi her zaman ne
iş yaptın oluyor çünkü bayılıyorum
gizliden gizliye bugüne kadarki çalıştım
arka yüzden Hava atmaya onlarla
böbürlenme filan Onun için bana
sorduklarında titre ne diyelim diye
kendini araştırmacı demek istedim çünkü
hani istedim ki siz böyle duyduğumuz
zaman hiçbir fikrim aramayın kafandan
atmış bitir olduğu için beni böyle bir
yere sınıflandırma mayın hem de Oh olsun
bana egonu yerle bir olsun ve hava Tamam
diye
çünkü ben aslında Artık kendime kalıcı
bir tanımıyorum bugüne kadar kendimi
işime şimdi üzerinden ne üzerinden
tanıdığınıza gibi vardı Onun için
istiyorum ki ben işimden çok daha
fazlası olduğum için bir tanım bulurum
kendime ve artık kendine Derine tanımaya
anlamaya ve kendini gerçekleştirmeye
çalışan yolcu NASA da aktaran sıradan
bir yolcuyu Mümkünse bana bugüne kadarki
başarılarından dolayı değil de şu an
burada dinleyeceğiniz kişi için saygı
gösterin Ben şimdi bir Podcast videosu
ile başladığı zaman pandül yeni başlamış
ucu Çünkü elimde yıl falan o şimdi
konforma döndü orası Hep de derdim ki
korkuyorum ki benim ilk sahne tecrübem
FedEx olacak şaka olmuş bugün
karşınızdayım Şimdi en büyük
Hayallerinden bir tanesi benim işte
toplumlara konuşmak sahnede olmak
millete seslenmek falan eğitimler vermek
onun içinde korkuyorum da bir tık Yani
inanılmazdı bir sahne korkum var diyorum
ki herhalde en derin Yani en güzel
başarılarım hazinem en derin korkunun
altından çıkacak İnşallah
ve onun içinde istediğimde Her şey
mükemmel olsun yani mükemmelleştirme
Çalıştım olayı işte ne yaptım Hemen
dedim Acaba bir konuşma bulsam beni eğit
hazırla sabuna sonra onu saldım Sonra
dedim ki tedef kitabı bir tane film var
o kitabı al ve bugüne kadarki en iyi
konuşmacılardan alıntılar neler nasıl
yapılır onu anlatıyor her sayfayı
çevirdim de bir tıkla yetersiz çıktım
kendime sonra Kenara koydum Neden
mükemmel yapmak istiyorum çünkü Eğer
karşınızda iyiçalışkan verimli kusursuz
hatasız durursam beni seveceksin
sağlayacaksınız ve ben başarılı
olacağına inanıyorum Beni eleştiri
geliştirebilecek Size yargılayacağız
inanıyorum bir şekilde Halbuki başla
samimiyet dediğim bir konuşma en güzel
samimi olarak yapılır gibi geliyor bana
çünkü
mükemmellikle samimiyet aslında tam zıt
kavramlar Yani ben bir şeyler
mükemmelleştirme çalıştığımda kitabını
uydurduğum da kalıbına sokmaya çalıştım
da hatasız kusursuz durmaya çalıştım de
belki mükemmel bir şeyler çıkartıyorum
Ama samimi olmayabiliyor kalpten kopmuş
olmayabiliyor ama Samimiyeti seçtiğim
zaman
karşınızda hatalı yapabilirim kusurlu
durabilirim kırıldı bu mutantların
korkuların hepsi çıkabilir Ama kalpten
bir şey paylaşmış olurum ve kalpten
paylaştığım zamanda sizinle derin bağ
kurmuş olurum ve ben bu hayata ve biz bu
hayata derin bağ kurmaya geldik Onun
için de zaten bugün size kendi hikayemi
anlatacağım ve Sizden ricam beni
dinlerken Mümkünse kendinizi duymaya
çalışmamız yani bana Aslında kendinizi
yansıtma nız Çünkü benim sorunlarımı
konularımı dinlerken göreceksiniz ki
konular benim sorunlar hepinizin ve
hepimizin Mayıs'ı Aslında ayrım Efendim
bundan 5-6 yıl öncesine kadar ben böyle
kendini insanlara sevdirir Ecem beğen
diyeceğim onay alacağım falan diye
yaptım bir böyle bir kul işte iyi havalı
insan tanımı vardı Ve hep kendime
uydurmaya çalışıyorum neydi Benimki
sporcu çılgın festivaller sıradışı
tatiller çılgın partiler çok iyi bir iş
eş ev araba filan neyse bunlar böyle hep
kendime bir kontrollü bu haldeydim de
böyle Aman diyordum yani İnsanlara Yeter
ki imajının zedelenmesini istiyorum bunu
uğraşıyordum bu sefer ne oluyor Yeni
birşeyleri adım atmaktan Konfor
alımından dışına çıkmaktan korkuyorum
Çünkü başarısız da olabilir ucunda ya da
mesela aptalca bulursa diye Fikri
paylaşmaya biliyorum birini Beğendim
benim mümkün diyorum açıla Bilmem
mağazalar reddedebilirim filan böyle
olduğu zaman Aslında kendim gibi değil
de toplumu uyuyacağım diye bir kalın
içinde yaşamaya başlıyorum bu şekilde
hayatlarını devam ediyor falan derken
bir dönem Ben hayatımda kendimi
üzerinden tanımladım ne varsa İşim eşim
Evim arama bunun hepsi benzer zamanlarda
kaybettim hayatında ve böyle olunca çok
canım acısın Tabii ki ve Öyle olunca
dayanamadım O acıyla Kalamadım kendime
Her zaman yaptığım gibi sokaklara attım
burada bu bilinçle yapmıyorum O zamanlar
işte kendime sigarayla alkolle
Parti ortam larıyla
bu fazladan belki işe vererek
televizyonla
telefon telefonumla yani sosyal medya
bir şeyleri sürekli böyle uyuşturma
çabasındayım sonra Şunu fark ettim yani
ben artık bu hali yaşamak istemiyorum
Çünkü fark ettim ki ben acımdan kaçmaya
devam ettiğim sürece Can sıkıntının
içinde oturdum müddetçe o can sıkıntısı
ve acı hiçbir yere gitmiyor yani ben
sadece onları paspasla üstünü örtmüş
oluyor bir şekilde ve orada duruyor
benim bu dönüşümü yaşam için yeni bir
şeye ihtiyacım var dedim ki Yasemin bu
acın içinde oturacaksın duracaksın
değişmesini dönüşmesini bekleyeceksin
Çünkü bugüne kadar Hadi dışarıya Muş
gibi yaptın sosyal medyada milli sandın
kendini kandırmaya ne kadar devam
edebilirsin diye sordum geldi Kendi
oturmaya başladım ve tahammül edemedim
arkadaşlar kendi Onun için size
soruyorum Siz bir odanın içinde Hiçbir
şey yapmadan kendinizi hiçbir şeyle
uyuşturmadan ne kadar kendi
düşüncelerinize başbaşa kalmaya tahammül
O benim hiç yoktu ben gerçekten
yapamadım ve böyle olunca hayatı yatsıyı
şeklini tamamen bir değişimden geçmesi
icat etti ve bir ruhsal çok 3 gibi bir
şey yaşadım Aslında ve ondan sonra
birazcık fark ettim ki aslında
düşünceleriyle başbaşa oturmamız sebebi
benim düşüncemin çoğunun negatif olması
dedim ki bir sorayım bu düşünceler bana
ne anlatmak istiyorlar da gördüm ki
Aslında o kendime tahammül edemediğim
taraflarım korkularım utanç
tetikleyicileri kırıldı allıklarım
kaygılarım ve fark ettim ki Aslında ben
bir bütün sameway bu evrende her şeyi
artısıyla eksisiyle geliyorsa o zaman
ben karanlıkları mı uyuşturmaya devam
ettiğim sürece yani Mesela korkuyu
sevmiyorum diye korku oluşturuyorum onu
yok sayımı düşünce içiyorum ama o zaman
cesur Dolanıyorum zaten Dolayısıyla ben
bu tarafı uyuşturmaya devam ettikçe
Aslında
pozitif diyebileceğim aşkı Samimiyeti
aidiyeti mutluluğu bu oluşturuyorum
Dolayısıyla karanlıkları Işık tutabilme
mi lazım ki ben hayatı bir bütün gibi
yaşayabilir mi Aslında samimiyetle önce
kendime sonra Başka insanlara bir hayat
yaşayabiliyorum bu sıralarda böyle
gidiyorum geliyorum falan falan hayranı
olduğum utanç ve kırılganlık
uzmanım bugün Ebru Hanım bir sözüne denk
geldim diyor ki
eğer kendin olmak istiyorsan özünden bir
hayat yaşamak istiyorsan ve iç huzurunu
sağlamak istiyorsan en önemli
kırılganlık kırılganlığı dedi de şu
mükemmel olmak zorunda değilim hata
yapabilirim diyebilmek ve kendine bütün
hallerini alan açmak demek aslında ve
dolayısıyla bütün karanlıklarını bütün
utandıkları nı korktukları hepsini
kendine katmak demek sonra ben
arkadaşlarıma aldım Onlara söyle
kaygılarımdan korkularımdan bahsetmeye
başladım bir baktım inanılmaz daha derin
daha kurmaya başladık onlardan açılıyor
ve ben aslında Yalnız değilim bu yolda
sonra kırılgan pazarlar ve bu sette
başladım Instagram'dan pazar günleri
paylaşıyorum insanlara cevaplar
yazıyorlar bugüne kadar sorduğum
sorulardan İşte en kendini en sık
söylediği yalan Hangisi en son hangi
bilginin doğru değişti gibi gibi böyle
Aslında derin Kazmanın gerektirdiği
kendini sorular soruyorum ve bir baktım
1500'e yakın insan cevap veriyor yani
bayağı insanların Aslında görülmeye
ihtiyacı var yargısız bir alanda
duyurmak istiyorlar birbirlerine
yorumlarına yorum atıyorlar filan ve
utandıkları şeyleri Aslında açıklıkla
paylaşıyorlar bu utandığımız şeyleri
açıklıkla paylaşmaktan çok korkuyoruz
yani görülür olmaktan Çünkü sanıyoruz ki
onlar sadece bir zararlar Onun için
onları izlemeye çalışıyoruz bir şekilde
siz zannediyor musunuz Ben utanmıyorum
zaman zaman içinden çıkabilen Narsist
kibirli yargılayıcı en yakın
arkadaşlarına bile hissettirebilen
yazacağım ya da Bazen insanlara karşı
uyguladığı stratejileri fark ediyor bu
çektiklerim gerçek olsun diye kıskandın
insanları dışarıya biliyorum ya da
beğendiğim böyle Hayran Olduğum kişilere
yer almaya çalışırken çok da bir çıkarım
olmayan insanlara küçüğüm sürebiliyorum
Dolayısıyla insanları gösterdim sevginin
ve saygının ne kadar yalan olabildiğini
görüyorum Bunlar hiçbir beni kötü bir
insana yapmıyor arkadaşlar insan yapıyor
Sadece
ben burada Size bunları anlatırken ne
kadar Rezalet bir kadınmış diye mi
dinliyorsunuz beni yoksa kendiniz mi
görüyorsunuz Ben de
korkularımız bile bir Bende olan
terkedilme reddedilme yetersizlik
başarısızlık gibi korkunç hiçbir bende
yoktu yani parmakları görebilir miyim
bende öyle sanmıştım kimse birbiriyle
paylaşmadığı için bunları kendimiz özel
zannediyoruz ve yalnızlaşıyoruz zamandan
Ve üstelik zannediyoruz gibi utandığımız
taraflarımı zayıflık Aslında aksine saç
dediğimiz şey
bu satıcılığın yeni şeylerin Aşkın doğum
yeri ve biz o utandığımız taraf larımızı
kendimize sakladık chao içimizde büyük
Çünkü utanç gizlilikten hoşlanıyor zaten
ama biz onları paylaştıkça onlara
özgürleşmeye başlıyor ve zaten yalnız
olmadığını görüyoruz bunu yapabilmek
için de bence kendimizi Derine tanımamız
gerekiyor birini tanımak için illa yola
meditasyon Defne Salih atmana gerek yok
dahaki bunu yapman gerekmez mi
istemiyorsun ama kendimizi derinde
kazmak zorundayız bence bunun en güzel
Metro'dan
kendinin hayatla ve insanlarla özel bir
ve en yakınlarını olan ilişkisini
gözlemlemek yani Sen hayatta en çok
nelere gıcık oluyorsun acaba bu gıcık
olduğun şeyleri zaman zaman sen de
yapıyorlar verir misin kimlerin ellerini
tahammül edemiyorsun acaba kendini
yansıtıyor olabilir misin onlara
nelerden Üstün görüyorsun kimlerden niye
Üstün görüyorsun kendini ne
zannediyorsun bütün bu soruları sormaya
başladı zaman aslında ve ilik hayatını
bir şeyler açılmaya başlıyor ve Evet
birazcık zorlu bir sürece girebiliyorsun
çünkü zor olabiliyor O taraflarında
bugüne kadarki kanlı taraflarına bakmaca
saati göstermek ve arkadaşlar Aslında bu
kusura hepimizde var yani çatlak larımız
var aslında ve o çatlaklardan içeriye
sızmak isteyen ışığa izin vermek
durumundayız Eğer bir bütün hayat
yaşamak istiyorsak samimiyetle bir hayat
yaşamak istiyorsak ve bilin ki o
çatlaklar sayesinde otantix yoksa zaten
herkes bir kalıba sıkışıyor Hepimiz
aynıyız bir farkımız yok birbirimizden
Ve onlar bizim en büyük hazinemiz bir
yandan o karanlık larımız ve kendini
açıklıkla ortaya koymanın ne kadar büyük
cesaret gerektirdiğini inanın
farkındayım ama
korktuğun halde adım atabilmektir
cesaret savunmasız kalmayı göze almaktır
Çünkü sen Cesur olmayı seçtiğinde
başarısızlığı hayal ve kalp kırıldığında
göz alır Oh
be bu dünyada şu anki düzende sana
Kendinden başka her şey olmanın
dinletildiği bir hayatta inatla israrla
samimiyetle kendin olmanın ne kadar zor
olduğunu yanın diliyorum ama Başkaları
ne der diye yaşayarak geçecek bir
hayattan daha zor olabileceğine
Gerçekten inanmıyorum Onun için
kendimize Işık tutmanın kendi
karanlığımda bakmanın çift önemli
olduğuna inanıyorum gerçekten öyle
düşünüyorum ve bilin ki biz kendimizi
mükemmelleştirme çalıştığımızda Ama
kimse bir beni görmesini görünmeyi
etmeyi uydururum kalıbına dediğimiz
zaman aslında o kadar da dedim bana
kuramıyoruz Evet mükemmel o zaman
mükemmel bir İlizyon ve Aslında biz
insanların uzaklaştırıyor o ben ne zaman
utandıkları mı kırılganlıkları Mı
korkularımı paylaşmaya başladım o zaman
zaten önce kendimle sonra etrafındaki
insanlarla samimi ilişki yaşamaya
başlıyorum Dolayısıyla okula hepimize
çevirmemiz gerekiyor Vatan bu Emre'nin
dediği gibi Arkadaşlar bu yol hiç içten
içe içten içe içe içe
biliyorum zorla alabileceğimizi zaman
zaman ama paylaştıkça kendimizi
göreceğiz ki aslında hepimizin mayası
aynı Hepimiz bir avuç suda nız bir avuç
toprakta nız Hiç kimsenin de böbürlenmek
çok da bir tarafı yok diğerinden
Unutmayın ki samimiyet ve cesaret
bulaşıcıdır kalp açıksınız daim olsun
[Alkış]